[Music]
that is hope the highroad from Jason is
Bolin the four hundred units new album
the Nashville sound which is out today
it is the sixth album for is Bowl the
singer-songwriter has won two Grammy
Awards and cracked the top ten of US
album charts he also has something else
to celebrate these days
mark Strassmann caught up with his bowl
on tour
[Applause]
at 38 Jason Isbell has become one of
Nashville's most acclaimed singer
songwriter he sings about heartache and
loss
[Music]
[Applause]
along with learning and redemption that
beat him but don't dare to him that
his will has lived all of that Tata
Jesus
his bowl just launched a six-month
international tour that will take him
from Cincinnati to Copenhagen backed by
his band the 400 unit thank you Sabitha
just offstage these crowds will not see
who else he brought on tour this young
devoted fan meet mercy his 21 month old
daughter it's a lot of fun to be able to
take her on the road and I'm really
dreading the time when that's gonna have
to stop you know there's a certain
responsibility there's a big
responsibility so I have to look at it
like what I want her to be around
somebody like me but early in his career
is bull acted like a child in his 20s
when he played with the group the
drive-by truckers by his own admission
is will drank a fifth of Jack Daniels a
day and loved cocaine how bad was it
back in the day when you were partying
hard it was so bad that I can't have one
drink
ever again that's got to be pretty bad
too much for the drive-by truckers in
2007 they kicked him out of the band he
also lost his marriage he got really
upset and told me he had a problem when
he couldn't you know quit drinking on
his own he tried it musician amanda
shires was the friend who refused to
give up on him just thought this person
is my friend and this person is asking
for helping that's what's gonna happen
and if it means that our relationship
doesn't survive then that's just what
it's gonna happen in 2012 he entered
treatment he has been clean and sober
ever since
a year later the woman who saved his
bowl became his wife
sometimes shires plays with his band but
mostly she's a solo artist and often on
a separate tour when baby mercy was born
they agreed sometimes she would tour
with her mother other times he would
become country music's mr. MA whatever
needed to be done I needed to know how
to do it just as well as my wife you
know for us to be able to really balance
the parenting thing which could be
humbling it was very humbling and it was
also terrifying because you know giving
a baby a bath is for the first time is
one of the scariest things I think you
can do on this whole lovelyz coming back
[Music]
after I quit drinking I thought I've got
a handle on this being an adult living
situation and then it baby comes in line
every corner becomes you know a death
trap every everything I see as like
somebody needs to put that away
somebody could trip and fall and hurt
themselves on this show your laminate
tell him I'm with the band what kind of
a dad is he the kind everybody wishes
they had he's a funny dad any plays a
games and change his diapers makes food
great a great dad parenting on the road
has brought his bowl a new focus mercy
is the real headliner in the is bull
family
[Music]
my wife may be the role model for our
daughter in some ways but I think I
represent what she'll put up with you
know I think one day she'll say okay my
dad behaved this way so if whoever I
happen to fall in love with behaves this
way it's got to be okay because I love
my day
his Ville has won two Grammy Awards but
he knows the prize that matters most is
the reward of raising a happy healthy
child who's that dad for CBS this
morning
mark Strassmann Springfield Missouri
he'll probably ask you to read him a
story
gosh may we all have a friend like
Amanda shires and when you're a little
girl your dad is the first man you fall
in love with so they're always watching
your daughter doing about the same age
turns to this week sorry what you're
still hoti transversus yes deathtrap era
every corner is baby the babies scary
yes Oh baby girls can do it for Fanta oh
my goodness gracious they can yeah look
at this